[Music]
all right the left obsessively continues
to push forward with their never- ending
Trump witch hunts now earlier today well
Trump defied the judge overseeing
far-left New York attorney general civil
fraud case against him and gave a
closing statement of a whopping five
minutes meanwhile Fulton County DA Fanny
Willis she continues to come under Fire
over her alleged romantic relationship
with the lead prosecutor in that Trump
case an outside Council paid over 650
Grand his name is Nathan Wade according
to those court documents she has been
subpoenaed to appear as a witness in his
divorce proceedings and a new bombshell
report from political revealing that the
January 6 committee helped guide the
early days of the Trump Georgia probe as
committee staff quietly met with
attorneys and agents working for Fanny
Willis in April of 2022 now besides
their steadfast pursuit of more Trump
witch hunts uh what else did the
Attorney General of New York and the da
in volton County Fanny Willis have in
common according to the visitor logs
both visited the Biden White House in
the last two years here with reaction
Trump legal spokesperson uh Alina habba
is back with us Alina great to have you
um let me see if I have this straight
here so you have the Attorney General of
New York meeting with the Biden White
House and White House counsel I assume
or I don't know who do we know who how
many occasions have you identified she
was in uh the Biden White House and what
was the time frame of that
sure uh we saw that there was a meeting
in August the month or two right before
they filed their complaint and there was
another meeting later in the midst of
our litigation on the Attorney General's
claim so that is twice confirmed I
believe there are also reports that she
had been at Miss Cala Harris's home this
is not normal she is a New York attorney
general voted by the New York
constituents and the only thing they all
have in common is the Soros backing I
cannot understand why she would have
cause in the middle of a trial to go see
the White House and the Biden
Administration let alone the top one of
the record said that they met on the
front lawn I can't believe what I'm
seeing I really can't and I am with you
Sean reporting with you every day I am
in the weeds and I still am shocked they
cease to amaze me this is unbelievable I
thought Georgia was bad and then today I
have to sit in court and get notice that
this person has now weaponized her which
we already knew but now that she's
coordinating as well with the Biden
Administration what was she there for
coffee we don't believe it
anymore and the joke of this is this
whole case is pending on the idea of
whether or not valuations that by the
way you have a disclaimer the Trump
organization had a disclaimer don't use
their valuations any company lending
money any company giving insurance they
have a fiduciary responsibility to do
their own valuation so it's a move Point
there's not a single person that's been
AG grieved in this case you have no
complaint from any anybody no lender no
insurance company I mean it's absurd on
on its face they want to seem seemingly
fulfill the campaign promise to go after
one man Donald Trump one family the
Trump family one organization the Trump
organization and completely cancel them
and then you've got Fanny Willis meeting
with the January 6 committee and and
then an outside Council she's hiring and
taking extravagant vacations with well
she met with the the j6 committee and
both of them went to the Biden White
House and by the way he charged fton
County for the hours that he was there
with Fanny Willis at the Biden White
House is that
correct can you imagine a world where
you're trying to be corrupt and then you
Bill your time to the corruption I mean
what planet are we living in honestly
the stupidity is amazing if it proves to
be true I really you got to get popcorn
at this point but it's not a joke Sean
these are real people the Trump
organization paid over $300 million in
taxes over the past few years to
employees this is about people that work
in the company this is about the kids
who won't be able to get a mortgage and
won't be able to take out a car loan
because Miss James and people like her
had a political agenda it's not a
question of fact is a fact there is
video footage of it and like I said
today in court not one piece after 3
years of Investigation not one piece
after 11 weeks shows that any of them
committed fraud all that it shows is one
thing desperation and election
interference it is pathetic it is
obvious and the American people get it
listen you're not meeting with the B doj
you're meeting with the bidens you're
meeting with Camala herself in her home
what is going on and when is our country
going to stop talking about it and start
doing something about it because they
have no problem doing something about it
when it's
Trump if if the case is mostly based on
valuations and this they're implying
that that President Trump put in
valuations that were not accurate but
yet you have a judge in the case that's
clinging to the the idiotic completely
moronic view that Mara Lago is worth a
mere $18
million I mean he would be more guilty
of anything that's even being alleged
against the Trump organization Am I
Wrong Sean he should get damages for how
much he's been prosecuted and how many
years he's had to pay for lawyers and
defending these garbage claims he should
get
damages okay I can tell you I know a
little bit about Florida real estate now
uh that property is worth closer to a
billion than 18 million uh you can't
even make this up in a novel but it's
sad that's Justice in America and it's
not working Alina Hobbit thank you hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else